en attendant noël jour 21 cette vidéo a
été réalisée dans le cadre du projet de
margaux de la chaîne vivre avec qui a
contacté plein de vidéastes pour
réaliser chacun une vidéo pour chaque
jour avant noël
le tout le mois de décembre en fait et
donc on était libre de choisir le thème
qu'on voulait et j'ai choisi de parler
de l'histoire des cadeaux de noël noël
tel qu'on le connaît se développent
plutôt au 19e siècle à l'époque les
cadeaux qu'on s'offrait on les appelle
plutôt des étrennes et ce sont des
cadeaux qu'on offre au jour de l'an dans
les familles aristocratiques et
bourgeoise ce sont des cadeaux souvent
de l'argent qu'on offre domestique mais
au fur et à mesure la pratique d'offrir
des étrennes à noël s'impose et on en
offre surtout aux enfants
au tout début du 19e siècle on achetait
ses étrennes dans des bains de loterie
c'était des petites boutiques éphémères
qui s'étale dans les villes dans
lesquelles on trouvait un peu de tout
des jouets en bois ou en plomb des
petits soldats des poupées en chiffon
des polichinelles des marionnettes en
carton ou en bois des meubles miniatures
aussi un petit peu tout ça c'était des
petites et très bon marché et on les
appelait des bains blot ses boutiques
animer les villes notamment les
boulevards parisiens et les petites
villes autour par exemple ont trouvé cet
humble au tri sur le pont neuf de paris
entre le 15 décembre et le 15 janvier
entre 1815 et 1835
tous les ans il revenait c'était donc un
sujet d'actualité les journaux aimé en
parler c'est apporter de l'animation et
on en retrouve la trace dans de nombreux
livres comme dans les misérables par
exemple tous à participer à l'esprit de
noël
en 1880 un arrêté préfectoral de paris
donne un autorisations aux familles
d'ouvriers de vendre certains objets
qu'elle aurait confectionné dans ces
petits étals pour les plus riches ont
acheté ces étrennes dans des magasins de
nouveautés qu'on appelle ensuite les
grands magasins il apparaît sous la
restauration et se développe très vite
en vendant un petit peu tout par exemple
le bazar de l'hôtel de ville le pot
marché le printemps les galeries
lafayette
tous ces magasins sont les exemples les
plus connus des magasins de nouveautés
et apparaissent ou cours du 19ème siècle
il met très rapidement noël en avant
parce qu'ils y faire un intérêt
commercial par exemple en 1827 la maison
alphonse duroux publie son premier
catalogue de l'exposition d'une variété
d'objets utiles et hague
abl offert pour les étrennes grâce à ces
catalogues on a une idée des articles à
la mode à cette époque on trouvait par
exemple des lampes des albums de
photographies et beaucoup de faux cils
la mode était aux fossiles pour les plus
riches ça pouvait aussi être des
reproductions en terre cuite d'objets
antiques de bronze par exemple mais
aussi été boîte à musique des lorgnette
pour le théâtre etc
la période de noël était aussi très mise
en avant par la presse dès 1836 on a par
exemple le journal la presse qui montre
les premières publicités de noël en 1841
il annonce d'ailleurs que ce sont les
livres reliés qui sont à la mode comme
les fables de la fontaine par exemple ou
robinson crusoé et les catalogues des
traînes se développe beaucoup ils sont
d'après le printemps en 1877 expédié à
la demande générale des clients pour
faciliter l'achat de leurs étrennes
en plus de ces catalogues qui sont donc
envoyés par tous les grands magasins
d'époque on met en place de plus en plus
des expositions de jouer dans les
boutiques d'immenses rayon dans
lesquelles les jouets sont mises en
avant et mis en valeur
c'est le cas par exemple au louvre
magasin du louvre en 1878 des affiches
aussi sont de plus en plus présentes
dans les villes elles sont soit fait par
des illustrateurs réputé de l'époque
soit par des anonymes et souvent le
personnage de polichinelle revient
beaucoup le père noël on connaît pas
encore beaucoup à cette époque il
apparaît à la fin du 19e siècle à la fin
de l'hiver 1890 il ya le magasin le
pauvre jacques jouet et rennes qui
présente un personnage qui est à mi
chemin entre le père noël pour koné et
les personnages d'avant c'est un grand
bonhomme avec une barbe blanche et une
cape verte et on n'appelle pas encore le
père noël et en 1898 le figaro et du str
est présente aussi un bonhomme de noël
on retrouve aussi ce bonhomme noël en
1906 sur une affiche des galeries
lafayette
alors qu'à côté de ça le bazar de
l'hôtel de ville fait toujours appel à
polichinelle comme symbole de noël à
partir de la fin du 19e siècle une autre
chose qui est mise en valeur pour noël
sont les vitrines de noël en 1893 le bon
marché à paris fait apparaître la
première vitrine de noël dans laquelle
on voit des personnages
patiner et à partir de là tout le monde
veut sa vitrine en 1910 la maison rouler
et des camps fait apparaître la première
vitrine animée parce qu'il vendait des
automates et en 1900 aussi le magasin du
louvre est le premier à présenter un
arbre de noël le plus grand arbre de
paris pour ce qui est des vitrines la
france n'est pas la pionnière elle
s'inspire de ce qui se faisait déjà aux
états unis et en angleterre dès les
années 1880 les états unis présentent
des vitrines dans les grandes villes de
l'est américain est principalement à new
york qui la ville de noël mais magasins
macy's par exemple à des vitrines dès
1880 en allemagne ça faisait longtemps
qu'on célébrer le noël en famille la
tradition protestante fait que s'était
implanté depuis plus longtemps dans les
moeurs
par contre la fête devient commercial
qu'à partir de la fin du 19ème début du
20e siècle
il s'échangeait déjà des cadeaux au
moins depuis 1815 envers les enfants
mais aussi entre adultes par contre la
fête qu'on connaît aujourd'hui en
allemagne se développe avec le folklore
du 19e siècle
c'est aussi aux allemands qu'on doit les
chants de noël qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
comme douce nuit qui est créé en 1818 et
mon beau sapin qui est date de 1826 en
allemand dans le texte à la fin du 19e
siècle
on parle donc toujours des trains et non
pas de cadeau de noël mais elles sont de
plus en plus offerts à noël et pas aux
nouvelles
les jouets des grands magasins sont
surtout destinés aux enfants bourgeois
on trouve des voitures mécanique les
bergeries des costumes militaires
dépasse bouille des jeunes massacre des
machines à coudre pour enfants etc etc
il existe aussi différents types de
cadeaux selon la baronne staff du 16e
siècle
il faut offrir aux personnes riches des
choses dont elles n'ont pas besoin des
objets inutiles aux personnes
moyennement riches il vaut mieux offrir
des objets qui pourront à la fois être
décoratifs et leur servir dans la vie de
tous les jours et aux personnes pauvres
il vaut mieux offrir des objets qui leur
seront utiles pour les cadeaux des
enfants il peut y en avoir d utiles
comme les albums photos par exemple ou
des livres des traînes ou des inutiles
des jouets ça reste utile déjoué dès le
début du 20e siècle on s'interroge aussi
sur le fait d'offrir de l'argent à noël
parce que ça peut être vu comme une
simple transaction donc c'est pas
forcément terrible mais
on considère que si l'argent est bien
emballé dans une décoration originale
dans ce cas-là ça en fait un vrai cadeau
et non pas juste une transaction est
aussi le cadeau d'argent et souvent
ascendant ce sont les parents ou les
grands-parents qui en offrent aux
enfants ou aux puces les enfants et
jamais l'inversé mon par contre avait
tout ça les petites boutiques dont je
parlais au début des bains de loterie
ont largement disparu à la fin du 19e
siècle
une autre innovation qui apparaît au fur
et à mesure c'est l'emballage au début
les cadeaux ont été offerts visible ou
alors vous était juste emballé dans un
papier blanc ou beige
à la fin du 19e siècle apparaissent les
emballages en cellophane et des jolis
rubans colorés qui permettent de ménager
l'effet de surprise et créer un peu plus
d'attentes au moment du déballage du
cadeau aux états unis il existait même
des christmas package partys donc des
sortes de ventes aux enchères ou les
personnes riches acheter des cadeaux
déjà emballé il ne savait pas ce qu'il y
avait dedans
au début du 20e siècle développe aussi
la décoration intérieure pour aller avec
la fête de noël en 1908 le bazar de
l'hôtel de ville publie un catalogue
dans lesquels il met en avant des
décorations pour la maison les
guirlandes par exemple et à partir de
1921 on peut aussi acheter les premiers
sapins artificiels dont l'arbre de noël
c'était pas nouveau dès 1840 la reine
victoria en fait inauguré à windsor et
les photos de cet arbre sont diffusées
partout en europe et en 1937 le
catalogue du magasin le bon marché
montre le premier vrai père noël
sauf qu'il a pas de traîneaux à cette
époque il conduit un bateau la
littérature dans tout ça participe aussi
à l'engouement pour l'esprit de noël par
exemple avec casse noisette de hoffman
et bien sûr avec les contes de noël de
charles dickens
il met en valeur l'esprit de noël mais
aussi la charité en montrant souvent des
enfants riches qui viennent en aide à
des enfants pauvres et d'ailleurs à ce
sujet il ya une très belle histoire qui
me vient en tête chemin plus sur ciel se
passe à la période de noël ou pas mais
si vous connaissez gilbert cesbron ou si
vous ne le connaissez pas lisez le il a
écrit traduit du vent qui est un très
beau livre un recueil de nouvelles
dans lequel l'une des nouvelles montres
un enfant pauvre on l'appelle le petit
enfant brun dans l'histoire il vit dans
la rue il vend des journaux et un enfant
riche le petit enfant blond et l'enfant
pauvre rencontre l'enfant riche en fait
ils le voient à travers la fenêtre de sa
maison il le faire entrer et là on a une
belle description de tous les jouets que
l'enfant que l'on possède aussi bien
déjouer un petit train électrique je
crois des jouets pour le bain et c'est
une belle histoire
et de toute façon ce recueil de
nouvelles est magnifique donc je vous
incite à dire traduit du vent c'était un
petit hors sujet pour terminer c'est
après la seconde guerre mondiale que
noël devient encore plus populaire déjà
parce qu'il s'inspire du modèle
américain avec des décorations de noël
dont je parlais à new york avec aussi le
père noël tu es plus en plus diffusée en
france et avec le baby boom et la
période d'abondance qui tua avec où tout
le monde a bien envie de dépenser pour
noël le cinéma américain permet aussi de
mettre en valeur nos l aidant catalogue
de 1950 le bon marché affiche
bienvenue au père noël ca affiche la
couleur la couleur rouge c'est là que
noël est donc de plus en plus populaires
et des familles sortent dans les rues
pour voir les vitrines on cuisine la
dinde également etc etc
donc j'espère que cet épisode vous a plu
et que vous passerez une meilleure
nouvelle possible si vous fêter noël et
dans tous les cas
bonne fin d'année 2010 est en janvier je
vous retrouve pour deux vidéos et je
vous incite à regarder le reste de ce
calendrier de l'avent dans toutes les
autres vidéos qui vont être mises en
ligne pour en attendant noël
même s'il y en as plus tant que ça
puisque je suis déjà jour 21 mais en
tout cas je vous mets le lien dans la
description voilà au revoir